ok
sure
the duo sea and air plays to a sold-out
club in Berlin the singer songwriters
are celebrating the release of a new
album elini superion who comes from
Greece and Daniel Benjamin from Germany
this banner to invoke fear is a clam the
band name is a play on words the English
words sea and air sound like the German
Z on air or she and II but the funny
part is that with us being Greek and
German the concept of sea and air fits
our personalities too Oh no ha after
playing together in other bands they
decided to form sea and air in 2011 and
right away they won awards with their
playful indie pop sound
sea and air are partners on and off
stage elini and Daniel have been married
since 2004 Baltic soonish spun around so
much tension builds up in our
relationship and you hear these extreme
feelings articulated in our music
article yet their new album is called
évreux p Greek for Europe their
inspiration came from the three years
they spent touring the continent through
22 countries getting to know people and
places up close and personal e they
condense their impressions into 12 songs
buffoon on scuba we feel at home all
over Europe because we have so many
friends and so many ties to all these
countries and no matter where we go we
always have someone who's door who's
house and heart is open to us you met in
designer 2f not for online house of nuts
unhappy follow me me me is the first
single from their new album and the
first single they've ever had in the
German charts
before a concert in a trendy bar above
the rooftops of Berlin the duo have come
here from their home in
baden-wuerttemberg with lots of luggage
in it is the Greek bouzouki bass pedals
keyboards and percussion on stage the
couple often play more than one
instrument even while singing and
talking to the audience this is only
human auto pilot like driving a car when
you first start learning you have to
think about finding the clutch shifting
gears watching the road and so on on
kosmos my Jewish often once you've
practiced a while it becomes second
nature and then you can concentrate on
other things constantly Anna but you
have to put a lot of practice into a 25
you won't see
soon
they connect with the audience through a
mix of old and new songs
see Emily a remarkable music and somehow
always knew sunam was the great music by
likable people and the audience is very
easy going to Hauser podras poopley cool
it was lots of fun really cool concert
eleni and Daniel have said they'd like
to have small enthusiastic audiences in
every European country and the way
things are going they will this autumn
after their German concerts are over
they'll continue their tour in Britain
care of my soul
cuz I know
Oh